alors vous vous êtes vous avez vu vous
avez vous avez des projets hier vous
m'avez adressé un petit mot faut réunir
intelligence proximité à certines ans à
la fois pour avoir la chance d'un
momentum
rien n'est jamais écrit le scénario
plausible mais pas avec hanouna pour une
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
de 2000 22 mois j'ai dit ce que j'en
pensais hier vous allez voir d'ailleurs
dans un instant il ya cyrille eldin qui
est allé pour nous à l'assemblée il a
même eu la réaction de christophe
castaner concernant la candidature ou en
2022 mais juste joakim noah la première
chose que je me suis dit quand j'ai dit
ça je me suis dit je vois qu'ils sont
forgés c'est sûr qu'il va vouloir galy
il va vouloir annoncer sa candidature
pour 2022 ce que je me trompe ou pas
mais coûte cyril moi je pense qu'à un
moment donné quand on pense qu'on a les
moyens de faire quelque chose pour son
pays il faut le faire savoir le courage
je suis pas quelqu'un qui sait qu'il ya
un suiveur je suis quelqu'un qui est
franc qui vient la campagne qui suit
plus elle accompagne aujourd'hui mais je
connais les deux mondes
j'aime les français dans leur diversité
dans leurs différences dans le fait
qu'ils soient de droite et gauche je
trouve que c'est respectable que les
gens soient ou de droite ou de gauche
c'est pas démoli tout ça mais il ya des
points de consensus il ya des choses à
faire affaire avec les français moi j'ai
envie de les faire
donc j'ai envie d'être candidat j'ai
envie de donc aujourd'hui vous nous
dites aujourd'hui je te dis cyril
aujourd'hui je dis aux téléspectateurs
au chroniqueur que je serai candidat
présidentiel 2022 parce que j'ai un
projet présidentiel à construire à
proposer aux français et on va le faire
et on va le faire avec alexandre on va
le faire avec plein de monde on va le
faire avec ce parti valeur absolue qu'on
a créés celle enfin peut-être avec toi
cyril également moi je vais pas te tais
lui et puis si jamais et si jamais le
veut pas aller en soirée libre les
personnes les personnes les personnes
c'est pas grave
c'est le projet qui compte joakim noah
est ici demain c'est si demain c'est pas
moi et si les français le demandent mais
moi je t'aiderai passé ce qui compte
c'est défendre ça s'appelle temps par
exemple valeur absolue valeur absolue
parce qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans un
monde dur relatif alexandre béral du
rôle d'assister chaque news et les gens
ils ont besoin d'absolu evans et
alexandre bédat là il n'est pas mis en
examen
alexandre benalla il est innocent il
évident sont mis d'accord mais ce
qu'elle est les huguenots jordan pour ça
qu'ils n'ont pas les accords récents
mois vous avez remarqué sur les réseaux
sociaux à chaque fois je les fonds des
gens qui sont lynchés public mais c'est
vrai y compris des gens où je peux tout
à fait d'accord avec toi que c'est vrai
pourquoi parce que je pense que le
lynchage médiatique exactement ça chez
la lapidation ça c'est vrai c'est le
sévère de l'être humain ça va cesser la
crasse de l'être humain la lapidation le
lynchage médiatique dont vous êtes il
faut défendre les gens qui sont lynchées
à tokyo n'arrivant pas à vous l'avais
dit à emmanuel macron vous étiez
candidat hier soir mais il est entendu
maintenant il est vendu ou voulait qu'on
l'appelle je vais dire il avait pas il
n'avait pas le temps hier il a dû donner
de l'attention à beaucoup de débuter
c'est normal
donc vous êtes officiellement candidat
vraiment je vous dis l'exclusivité de sa
candidate céleri et joachim moi je vous
le dis si vous croyez en vous si vous
avez envie d'aller au bout du truc
allez-y et franchement moi j'aime bien
venir hakim parce que c'est un mec très
intelligents et qui est qui sort du
sérail et s'engage vous êtes un
personnage très sympathique voilà je
voulais vous le dire franchement c'est
vrai qu'ils ont acquises au team voilà